you know I would like to spend a little
more time ways in which people can
invite the unconscious to manifest it
can come through you know real
disturbance a stuckness a life decision
that's emotionally anguishing and it can
come through some kind of kind of an
epiphany a dream image or some such
thing and what I particularly like about
what young wrote is that we can invite a
new situation we can invite a symbol by
going into an issue or an image
consciously there's no guarantee we're
not commanding the unconscious thou
shalt show up but we can at least open
ourselves to the unconscious through
through art through a meditative walk
through some specific kinds of
journaling even going to sleep at night
and asking for a dream and having
something to write it down with so
consciousness can play a leading role of
kind of opening the door if you will and
what I love that Jung said about this is
it is a way of attaining liberation by
one's own efforts of finding the courage
to be oneself so we don't just have to
sort of sit and wait and hope we we can
invite the unconscious to dialog to play
to have a discussion confrontation maybe
even a little arm wrestling and this is
so central to the development of
consciousness that the creative tension
and the dance between our known
personality and this mysterious
unconscious realm is what causes us to
and for me why it is tragic that
cognitive behavioral therapy and other
modern therapies devalue or refuse to
honor that unconscious dimension yeah
that the ego on its own no matter how
clever it is cannot achieve that fecund
state that the unconscious can provide
that's such a good point Joseph because
some of these other therapies that don't
take into account the unconscious really
are just aiming to sort of shore up a
conscious functioning and perhaps even
making it more difficult to get that
input from the unconscious I'm really
glad you brought that up and Young is
very clear at one point he says you know
in most cases you know analysis of
consciousness is not enough and in order
to have a new attitude and be in a new
psychic situation the unconscious does
have to be engaged and a new
relationship to the issue that holds
both unconscious and conscious
perspectives has to be achieved yeah I
wish in a way it weren't so wouldn't it
be great if we could just engage in
problem-solving and creative solutions
and so on but as unions we know through
our own experience and through work with
clients and so many other things that
this is just psychic fact that the
unconscious has to have its say and that
as we pluck up the courage
to tend to the unconscious it doesn't
mean we tacitly agree with it but that
we're just willing to have a
conversation one of the hopeful things
for me is that regardless of whether or
not we believe there is an unconscious
every night the most rational people in
the world still have dreams and they're
sitting there over the kitchen table
well you know having their egg sandwich
talking about how they you know we saw a
dragon last night or laughed about you
know their boss wearing a funny hat in a
dream and at least acknowledging the
images and feelings of a dream allows
the unconscious to slowly introduce
something at least on a feeling level
now if we go into the dream really
trying to unpack the mystery of it
more of the unconscious wisdom can
become available